♪♪
Narrator:
HE INSERTS THE MAIN DRIVE MOTOR
AND THEN SECURES IT
TO AN ALUMINUM PARTITION
WITH THE SHAFT PROTRUDING
THROUGH THE OTHER SIDE.
HE THEN WRAPS THE DRIVE CHAIN
AROUND THE SPROCKETS
OF THE SHAFT.
HE LOOPS A RUBBER BELT
IN FRONT OF THE BUFFER BRUSH
AND CONNECTS IT
TO THE OIL APPLICATOR.
THE APPLICATOR
WILL SLIDE ON THE BELT,
DISPENSING SMALL AMOUNTS
OF CONDITIONER.
HE INSTALLS WHISKER SENSORS
TO THE FRONT ON EACH SIDE.
WHEN THESE WHISKERS
BRUSH THE SIDES OF THE LANE,
THEY'LL SEND A SIGNAL
TO THE COMPUTER,
WHICH WILL THEN DIRECT THE ROBOT
TO MOVE MORE TO THE CENTER.
THE CONDITIONING SOLUTION TANKS
HAVE BEEN EQUIPPED
WITH METERING PUMPS
AND PRESSURE GAUGES.
HE BOLTS THE ASSEMBLY
TO THE REAR WALL OF THE MACHINE.
HE POPS IN
THE RECHARGEABLE BATTERY
AND CONNECTS IT TO THE MOTOR.
THE MACHINE IS READY
FOR THE COMPUTERIZED SYSTEM
THAT RUNS IT.
THIS SYSTEM INCLUDES
THE CONTROL PANEL.
HE INSTALLS IT IN THE CENTER
OF THE MACHINE,
JUST ABOVE THE BATTERY.
HE THEN RUNS THE HOSE
FROM THE CONDITIONING TANK
OVER TO THE APPLICATOR
AND CONNECTS IT.
MOVING TO THE FRONT,
ANOTHER EMPLOYEE UNWINDS FABRIC
FROM ONE ROLLER AND ATTACHES
THE END TO THE NEXT.
THIS IS PART
OF THE CLEANING SYSTEM.
THE CLOTH WILL SCRUB
THE BOWLING LANE
AFTER THE ROBOT SPRAYS
A CLEANING SOLUTION ONTO IT.
A SUCTIONING SQUEEGEE
WILL VACUUM UP DIRT
AND LEFTOVER CLEANER
AND DEPOSIT THEM
IN THIS RECOVERY TANK.
HE THEN PLUGS THE WIRING HARNESS
INTO THE COMPUTER AT THE BACK
OF THE CONTROL PANEL.
IT'S TIME FOR A DRY RUN.
WITH NO CLEANER OR CONDITIONER
IN THE SYSTEM YET,
THE TECHNICIAN POWERS
UP THE ROBOT
AND PUTS IT THROUGH ITS PACES.
HE CONFIRMS THAT EVERY PART
IS IN GOOD WORKING ORDER.
HE ADDS CLEANING SOLUTION
TO THE TANK,
AND IT'S TIME PREPARE
THE LANE CONDITIONERS.
THEY MIX THE MINERAL
OIL-BASED CONDITIONERS
IN BIG BLENDERS.
THERE ARE NINE DIFFERENT
RECIPES,
WITH UP TO 16 INGREDIENTS
IN EACH ONE.
WITH THE CONDITIONERS APPROVED,
IT'S TIME TO TEST THE ROBOT
IN SPECIAL QUALITY
CONTROL LANES.
DURING 50 TRIPS
DOWN THE LANES,
A TECHNICIAN EVALUATES
THE ROBOT'S PERFORMANCE.
HE INSPECTS ITS TURNING RADIUS
AND THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THE SENSORS.
HE ALSO SCRUTINIZES THE CLEANING
AND CONDITIONING JOB.
SATISFIED
THAT THE CONDITIONING ROBOT
WORKS WELL ON ITS OWN,
HE APPROVES IT FOR SHIPPING.
THIS BOWLING LANE CONDITIONER
SHOULD BE A REAL GAME CHANGER
AND ENSURE THAT THE PATH
TO VICTORY IS A WELL-OILED ONE.